hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the nineteenth of August when you're
tuned into gamespot news that major ps4
system update we told you about a couple
of weeks ago is getting itself a beta in
US and European regions here's how you
can be a part of it the beta will
officially begin in early September
according to the PlayStation Blog if
you'd like to join in you'll need to
have an internet-connected ps4 and a pfn
master account to qualify the signup
process simply calls for you to enter
your PSN name on the official
PlayStation website although Sony up
said there are a limited number of spots
so this won't necessarily guarantee you
access to the beta if you get in you'll
be able to revert your system back from
three point O to the current firmware
2.57 at any time Sony still haven't
officially confirmed what's in the new
updates but we expect it to introduce
communities youtube broadcasting support
and twitter video supports Rocksteady
have revealed what's coming up for
Batman Arkham Knights next DLC pack
September first will deliver the first
of the games crime fighter challenge
packs which includes 6ar challenges for
Batman Nightwing Robin and chaplain the
developer have also announced that later
in the month fans will be treated to the
2008 tumblr Batmobile pack which is
inspired by Christopher Nolan's the dark
knight if you're after something a
little more vintage the 1989 Batmobile
launched for Arkham Knight just this
week also arriving late in September are
an original Ark and Batman skin and a
new Nightwing story pack where you'll
need to thwart penguin xbox pottsville
spencer is suggested we're going to hear
about more xbox backwards compatible
games later this week asked my fans on
Twitter when we're likely to hear about
more backwards compatible 360 titles
Spencer replied looks like you should
hear some music
sweet an optimistic van noten they'd
love to see red dead redemption on that
list but Spencer didn't give any
indication of which games are likely to
be announced in the next batch the most
requested games are backwards
compatibility is call of duty black ops
2 followed by a red dead redemption let
me go down in that comment box which
last generation game you'd like to see
on current-generation consoles you can
add the game spot we've got stories and
blizzards support plans for half stone
and a new trailer for middle gear solid
5 4 phantom pain that is everything I
wanted to tell you about today we should
let me know what mattered to you and I
will catch you same time tomorrow